nous reprenons nos travaux
c'est le rapporteur général chers
collègues nous recevons ce matin
Monsieur François Villeroy de Galloux
gouverneur de la Banque de France je me
permets de saluer Monsieur le Gouverneur
vous remercier de votre présence
évidemment de vous adresser ainsi qu'à
l'ensemble des personnages de la Banque
de France et au nom de notre commission
mes meilleurs vœux pour cette nouvelle
année
votre audition ce matin un caractère
relativement traditionnel puisque nous
avons pris l'habitude depuis des années
de vous retrouver au mois de janvier
à noter que l'année dernière après votre
reconduction du mois d'octobre nous
avions reçu le directeur général de la
statistique des études économiques
internationales de la Banque de France
dans le cas d'une table ronde aux côtés
notamment de l'INSEE pour évoquer le
sujet de l'inflation et de ses
conséquences
l'importance de ce sujet est loin de
s'être estompée comme le montre vos
préoccupations vos prévisions pardon
macroéconomiques les plus récentes qui
indique que l'inflation et l'indice des
prix à la consommation harmonisée
devrait atteindre 6%
en 2023 soit le même niveau
quand 2022
de façon générale le contexte
macroéconomique reste fortement dégradé
en raison notamment de la persistance de
la crise énergétique mais aussi d'une
politique monétaire de plus en plus
restrictive mise en oeuvre vous aurez
l'occasion nous en rendre compte pour
maîtriser l'inflation des prix ainsi en
2023 selon vos prévisions la croissance
du PIB devrait se limiter à 0,3%, ce qui
bien sûr est faible et laisse en
définitive peu de marge de manœuvre pour
encaisser les chocs que nous pourrions
subir
au-delà des considérations
macroéconomiques vous avez insisté à
plusieurs reprises dans vos prises de
position publique sur la nécessité pour
les gouvernements de limiter rapidement
le déficit budgétaire compte tenu de la
dégradation de leur condition de
financement là encore nous serons
sensibles à votre expression sur un
sujet qui relève de la politique
budgétaire mais qui n'est naturellement
pas sans intérêt pour les banquiers
centraux et pour nous tous
figure également au nombre de vos
attributions la régulation du secteur
bancaire et nous serons sur ce point
également heureux de vous entendre tant
sur les conséquences de la remontée des
taux sur l'accès des entreprises des
ménages au crédit que sur la santé du
secteur bancaire et corrélativement sur
l'état des travaux cela transposition
des accords internationaux de balles 3
il semble que les choses s'accélèrent
puisque le Conseil d'Union européenne a
trouvé un accord sur le sujet en
novembre dernier
beaucoup de sujets ce qui fait que je
vais vous céder la parole sans plus
attendre Monsieur le Gouverneur avant
évidemment de prendre les questions de
nos collègues cette audition et comme il
est de tradition bien évidemment
retransmise sur le site internet du
Sénat Monsieur Bernard
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Rapporteur général mesdames et messieurs
les sénateurs c'est moi qui vous
remercie sincèrement monsieur le
Président c'est une tradition comme vous
l'avez rappelé mais cela ne diminue en
rien le plaisir de ma part et j'espère
l'intérêt de ce rendu compte
devant la représentation nationale alors
évidemment dans cette période je formule
tous mes vœux les plus chaleureux pour
vous et ceux qui vous sont chers pour
notre pays et prouver comme toute
l'Europe par la guerre à ses portes et
la crise énergétique qui en a découlé ce
contexte génère beaucoup d'incertitudes
vous l'avez dit j'essaierai néanmoins
dans ce propos introductif de donner
trois séries de repères pour l'année qui
s'ouvre de répondre ainsi à un certain
nombre de questions que vous avez
évoquées mais on pourra évidemment
prolonger dans la suite de notre
discussion
premièrement sur la conjoncture et
l'inflation ensuite sur le financement
de l'économie et la situation de nos
entreprises et enfin sur l'adaptation
durable à cette nouvelle donne
alors sur la conjoncture si je devais
résumer d'une phrase je dirais que
jusqu'à présent l'activité nous a plutôt
surpris en bien et l'inflation plutôt
surpris en mal
l'économie française a résisté avec une
croissance qui devrait s'établir à 2,6%
en 2022 cette résilience meilleure que
prévu vaut également pour la zone euro
nous venons à la BCE de relever la
prévision de croissance 2022 à 3,4%
selon nos prévisions Banque de France
publiant décembre 2023 cette année
devrait marquer un fort ralentissement
mais mais échappé à l'atterrissage
brutal qui était redoutée il y a
quelques mois nous venons de publier ce
matin notre dernière enquête mensuelle
de conjoncture réalisée auprès de 8000
chefs d'entreprises notamment de PME
elle marque encore une fois cette
résilience meilleure que prévu et elle
conforte notre prévision de plus 0,3%
donc une croissance faiblement positive
pour 2023 tandis que 2024 marquerait la
reprise avec une croissance de
1,2% dans notre pays
voilà pour l'activité mais il y a
évidemment l'inflation après une
décennie d'inflation trop basse et même
on s'en souvient un risque de déflation
en 2020 l'inflation est revenue si elle
a légèrement diminué en décembre à 6,7 %
en France je précise je raisonne ici en
indice européen harmonisé l'indice
national et lui à 5,9% que l'on prenne
l'un ou l'autre le niveau de l'inflation
reste beaucoup trop élevé les ménages et
les entreprises le ressentent d'ailleurs
fortement
alors l'inflation en France devrait
atteindre son pic au cours de ce premier
semestre avant de redescendre vers 4% en
fin d'année
mais je veux redire ici ce qui est à la
fois notre prévision et notre engagement
nous allons ramener l'inflation vers 2%
d'ici fin 2024 à fin 2025 c'est notre
mandat et l'inflation est aujourd'hui
vous le savez encore mieux que moi la
première préoccupation de nos
concitoyens
en outre une inflation qui
s'installerait durablement serait le
pire ennemi de la confiance et donc de
la croissance
ceci me conduit monsieur le Président la
politique monétaire actuelle dont vous
avez parlé et nous entendons parfois des
questions évidemment légitimes dans
notre débat démocratique pourquoi
remontez-vous les taux d'intérêt en quoi
efficace alors que l'inflation est
d'abord née des prix de l'énergie
la première réponse est que
malheureusement l'inflation s'est
propagée à la généralité des biens et
des services
nous regardons l'inflation dit
sous-jacente c'est-à-dire hors énergie
alimentation elle est aujourd'hui autour
de
4,2%
donc nettement au dessus de la cible de
2% et elle ne baisse pas la différence
de l'inflation totale or c'est sur cette
inflation que j'appellerai général que
la politique monétaire est pertinente
notre conseil des gouverneurs a donc
décidé d'augmenter les taux directeurs
de la BCE arythme accéléré sur les cinq
derniers mois de 2022 de 250 points de
base au total et ce faisant nous avons
atteint à 2% de taux directeur ce qu'on
pourrait estimer la zone de
normalisation dans laquelle la politique
monétaire ne stimule ni ne restreint
l'inflation
alors en 2023 de nouvelles hausses de
taux seront très probablement nécessaire
dans les prochains mois un rythme
pragmatique je souligne cet objectif qui
m'est cher pour faire revenir
l'inflation vers 2% je les dis dans les
deux ans pourquoi dans les deux ans
parce qu'ils sont le délai d'action de
la politique monétaire
mais toujours et partout
et nous commençons à le voir aujourd'hui
aux États-Unis au Canada la politique
monétaire est efficace pour maîtriser
l'inflation
j'ajoute pour maîtriser l'inflation
c'est bien ça notre objectif et non pas
pour provoquer la récession j'ai entendu
monsieur le Président votre
interrogation là-dessus notre
interrogation à laquelle je bon là aussi
nous pourrons parler plus longuement
mais notre objectif c'est évidemment pas
de provoquer une récession c'est de
maîtriser l'inflation ceci m'amène à mon
deuxième point sur ou deuxième repère
sur le financement de l'économie et la
situation de nos entreprises le
relèvement des taux d'intérêt après
plusieurs années où ils ont été
anormalement bas se transmet aux
conditions de financement de l'économie
mais de façon progressive et ordonnée
alors je vais prendre le cas du crédit
immobilier qui est évidemment très
sensible pour nos concitoyens parmi les
grands pays européens la France est
celui ou le crédit immobilier est à la
fois le moins cher avec un taux moyen de
1,9% or assurance en novembre
je vous cite la moyenne de la zone euro
sur le même mois de novembre est à 2,8%
et plus frappant encore l'Allemagne est
à 3,6% donc là il y a un avantage
significatif et tant mieux du crédit
immobilier en France le crédit
immobilier est par ailleurs le plus
abondant avec une croissance des encours
qui est encore à 5,7% sur un an et point
peut-être moins connu le plus sûr avec
plus de 97% des encours atophistes alors
que plusieurs de nos voisins ont une
part très significative d'en cours à
taux variable donc de mensualité qui
augmente actuellement pour les ménages
l'encours des crédits bancaires aux
entreprises progresse plus fortement
encore à plus 7,7% en novembre
et donc globalement je souligne le
globalement les besoins de financement
de l'économie réelle restent largement
satisfait grâce à la solidité des
banques françaises
alors ceci m'amène au relèvement des
taux de l'épargne réglementée qui sera
fixé vendredi prochain
ma recommandation au ministre devra
prendre en compte dans ces quelques
possibilités d'ajustement le bon
équilibre entre d'un côté la juste
rémunération des pannes populaires et de
l'autre côté la préservation d'un coup
de financement raisonnable de notre
économie dont en particulier le logement
social
à cet égard il me paraît probable et
souhaitable que le relèvement du lepp le
Livret d'Épargne Populaire
soit en taux encore plus significatif
que celui du livret A sur CEP il faut se
féliciter que l'année écoulée est vue un
nombre record d'ouverture de plus de 2
millions de nouveaux livrés et que le
nombre total de détenteurs du coup
approche désormais les 8 millions et
demi
je voudrais parler un peu de la
situation de nos entreprises évidemment
largement touchées par la crise
énergétique leur trésorerie s'est
dégradé en particulier dans l'industrie
comme le confirme notre dernier enquête
mensuelle ce matin mais il y a en fait
de grandes variations entre entreprises
alors nous sommes extrêmement vigilants
sur l'allongement des délais de paiement
au PME et TPE de la part de certaines
entreprises de plus grandes tailles ce
n'est évidemment pas acceptable
quelques éclairages cet égard ce sont
selon nos estimations ce serait 16
milliards d'euros de trésorerie qui
seraient indûment capté par certaines de
ces grandes entreprises et nous avons
commencé grande nouveauté de 2022 à
surveiller ses comportements de paiement
pour ces filiales de grandes entreprises
ou de TI financièrement solides pour 10%
d'entre elles nous avons dégradé leur
notation d'un cran en conséquence de
mauvais comportement de paiement en 2023
cette opération visant la dégradation
éventuelle de la cotation en cas de
mauvaise comportement de paiement sera
élargi à trois fois plus d'entreprises
qui seront ainsi examinées
je veux aussi évoquer les PGE qui sont
évidemment un autre sujet très important
pour vous nous avons reçu en 2022 au
titre de la médiation du crédit
598 demandes exactement presque 600 de
restructuration ce qui représente
seulement moins de 0,1% du nombre total
de PGE
sur les 143 milliards d'euros de PGE des
boursins en 2020 qui ont été plus de 700
000 entreprises je vous précise que 40
milliards ont déjà été remboursés et
qu'aujourd'hui plus de 95% des
entreprises rembourse correctement leur
PGE par conséquent cela ne me semble pas
justifier une mesure de réelonnement
généralisé mais la médiation du crédit
de la Banque de France reste mobilisée
dans chacun de vos départements pour
traiter les cas plus difficiles
je termine si vous voulez bien par le
troisième repère que j'avais évoqué
comment est-ce que nous pouvons passer
progressivement de la gestion de crise
qui a beaucoup dominé 2022 à une
adaptation durable à ce qui est une
nouvelle donne cette gestion de crise
elle a été elle reste nécessaire
cependant je crois qu'il est important
de souligner que l'État peut amortir
temporairement le choc énergétique mais
il ne peut pas le faire disparaître
pour le dire autrement ça n'est pas
seulement un mauvais moment à passer
c'est une nouvelle donne économique à
laquelle nous devons nous adapter dans
la durée
et il faut donc progressivement d'ici 2
à 3 ans ramener vers zéro les
subventions budgétaires à l'énergie
et il faut vivre répartir plus
efficacement la facture entre les
entreprises et les ménages en veillant à
la fois l'équité envers les ménages par
des mesures mieux ciblées vers les plus
touchées mais tout autant à la
compétitivité de nos entreprises
les décisions du gouvernement
d'augmenter les tarifs du gaz et
d'électricité de 15% dans les prochaines
semaines et de remplacer la ristourne
soit essence par une indemnité de 100
euros ciblés selon les revenus me semble
à cet égard aller dans le bon sens y
compris je crois que c'est important
pour inciter à la sobriété énergétique
mais à terme et je vais en conclure par
là la clé bien sûr tout ce qui musclera
notre capacité productive par les trois
grandes transformations de de l'offre
économique ces trois grandes
transformations c'est la transformation
énergétique bien sûr en premier lieu la
transformation numérique et la
transformation du travail qui doit être
à la fois plus abondant et plus
qualifiés notre croissance qui gagnera
et notre inflation en sera mieux
maîtrisée d'avoir ainsi une meilleure
offre
pour le dire d'une phrase l'arme de la
victoire durable contre l'inflation
n'est pas budgétaire elle est d'abord
monétaire et ensuite structurel
mais cette transformation ne seront
possibles que si nous préservons notre
capacité à investir dans la
décarbonation et l'innovation ceci
m'amène à nos finances publiques sur un
dernier mot la dette publique atteint
désormais près de 114% du PIB nous ne
pouvons pas nous permettre un nouveau
quoi qu'il en coûte qui serait
d'ailleurs inefficace et nous devons
mieux maîtriser les dépenses courantes
nous devons en outre et monsieur le
Président c'est le rapporteur général
nous en avons parlé souvent ici mieux
financer mieux développer des
financements privés notamment en
réalisant enfin en Europe une union
verte des marchés de capitaux
je termine par là où j'ai commencé sur
mes vœux initiaux je crois que la France
et l'Europe peuvent en ce début d'année
avoir un peu davantage confiance en leur
capacité à affronter cette crise soyez
assurés en tout cas que la Banque de
France restera totalement mobilisé pour
cela en 2023 à votre service et celui de
nos concitoyens
merci Monsieur le Gouverneur c'est le
rapporteur général
oui merci Monsieur le Gouverneur à mon
tour est comme le président de vous
souhaitez à vous et vos équipes des
bons vœux des souhaits sincères de
[Musique]
réussite dans vos missions et peut-être
dans le
partage des éléments d'appréciation pour
avoir une connaissance la plus aboutie
et peut-être des avis les plus éclairés
sur la situation de notre pays
il se trouve
que sur vous avez vous avez abordé à
juste titre le sujet de l'inflation
vous avez évoqué un mot que j'aime bien
aussi le pragmatisme j'avais mis
quelques doutes des juillet
2021 sur le risque d'une vague
inflationniste
alors évidemment je ne suis pas
prévisionniste je ne pouvais pas la
prévoir à la hauteur de
qui est celle à laquelle elle frappe
l'Europe et la France dans une moindre
mesure mais pourquoi je dis ça parce que
je méfie toujours de phénomènes nouveaux
qui avaient plutôt disparu et un moment
ou un autre la nature fait que
[Musique]
il y a comme un risque quasiment
systémique de retrouver de je dirais de
vieilles
observation pratique et contrairement à
vous je ne lis pas en tous les cas pas
autant que vous dans votre propos
l'inflation à la crise ou à la flambée
des prix des énergies ou à la guerre en
Ukraine pardon mais bien à la flambée
des prix des énergies qui provoquent
je dirais un chamboule tout dans
l'organisation habituelle et le
fonctionnement de nos économies puisque
à ma connaissance c'est depuis bien
longtemps
a fait inédit et qui nous montre de
quelle manière nos économistes sont
intimement liées dans leur développement
au prix et à la desserte au réseau des
énergies de toute nature je vais
aborder rapidement trois questions
Monsieur le Gouverneur le premier vous
l'avez abordé également sur la question
de l'immobilier et moi j'appellerai ça
le sujet de l'investissement des ménages
dont vous notez qu'il devrait diminuer
fortement en 2023 et 2024 de -13 en 2023
presque moins deux en 2024 ce qui
évidemment ne sera pas sans lien avec la
croissance vous l'avez évoqué remonter
des taux d'intérêt
vous avez récemment proposé de réunir
les acteurs concernés
afin de revoir éventuellement les règles
d'actualisation du taux d'usure
notamment en passant à une révision qui
pourrait être mensuelle
quelles sont vos intentions et en tous
les cas quelles sont les perspectives
que vous dressez du marché immobilier
dont vous dont on peut considérer qu'il
est un baromètre assez fidèle de l'état
d'esprit de l'opinion et de la confiance
que ça veut dire par rapport à l'avenir
je note avec un peu de surprise et donc
je souhaiterais dans un deuxième temps
que vous nous précisiez ce qui vous
amène à avoir des précisions des
prévisions pardon sur l'emploi total qui
devrait de se stabiliser
en 2023 et puis diminuer en 2024 puisque
vous prévoyez en 2025 un taux de chômage
un peu supérieur à 8%, ce qui me semble
très sensiblement éloigné de des
prévisions alors je ne sais dire si
elles sont trop optimistes du
gouvernement qu'est-ce qui vous amène
aujourd'hui à ce stade avoir une vision
prospective aussi différenciée des
chiffres que nous annonce notamment le
ministre de l'économie et des finances
Bruno Le Maire
quelle conclusion attirez-vous sur à la
fois le l'évolution de nos finances
publiques et peut-être des gains
attendre de la réforme de l'assurance
chômage enfin dernier sujet il le plus
complexe c'est
la question de la BCE qui travaille
actuellement d'ailleurs avec l'ensemble
des banques centrales nationales sur le
projet d'un euro numérique finalement
pour créer l'équivalent au numérique de
ce que nous avons
en biais actuellement avec vous le savez
un centre de crainte ou de critiques de
la part des acteurs bancaires sur le
risque d'un phénomène de
désintermédiation peut-être même de
fuite de dépôt vers la banque centrale
et récemment un article de presse
présenté d'ailleurs cette heureux
numérique comme une un risque
démocratique ce qu'il pourrait porter
atteinte à certains d'informations
relatives à la vie privée et personnelle
de l'ensemble des détenteurs parce que
son utilisation d'ailleurs serait
programmable ce qui n'est pas sans
inquiéter la place et en tout cas les
Français ce que vous pourriez à ce stade
nous décrire
l'état d'avancement du projet et
peut-être les précisions relatives aux
craintes qui se sont exprimés à ce sujet
que je viens de relever
merci monsieur le rapporteur général je
glisserai une question supplémentaire ou
en tout cas vous demander une un petit
peu les termes de la discussion
aujourd'hui au sein de la BCE on sent à
travers un certain nombre d'articles
qu'il y a des positions de lancer on va
dire
vous voyez que je suis utilisé un
vocabulaire là aussi
prudent mais sur d'ailleurs le point que
vous avez relevé dans mon propos
introductif et qui était là pour ça
d'ailleurs qui était de faire le lien
évidemment entre la remontée des taux et
finalement
l'avenir de l'économie
l'impact sur la croissance etc et de
toutes de tout temps la question la
question monétaire c'est RTS à cette
question là c'est-à-dire de à la fois
d'avoir un impact pour maîtriser
l'inflation ou en tout cas pour la
mettre bon niveau et puis de l'autre
côté ne pas avoir un effet destructeur
sur l'économie mais est-ce que vous
pourriez nous dire en quelques mots
comment dire l'état du débat au sein
même de la BCE si je puis dire si vous
êtes question puisqu'il me semble qu'il
y a des avis un peu je dirais pas
disparate ce serait des agréable mais
différent voilà c'est
donc je vais d'abord répondre aux
questions du rapporteur général
d'abord je vous donne tout à fait avec
Monsieur Laurent partagé de ce que vous
avez dit sur
les discussions sur l'inflation
commencer en 2021 effectivement que vous
faisiez partie de ceux
nous n'étions pas dans un camp opposé à
l'époque d'ailleurs mais qui qui
s'alarmait du retour de l'inflation à
l'époque la cause en était souvenez-vous
la sortie très rapide du covid avec la
reprise de l'économie un certain nombre
de goulet d'étranglement voilà je crois
qu'il y a eu deux débats à l'époque et
je veux pas être trop long est-ce que
c'est un phénomène temporaire et les
entreprises elles-mêmes dans la même
enquête mensuelle de conjoncture je
citais il y a un an les entreprises
s'attendaient à ce que ces difficultés
d'approvisionnement disparaissent très
largement d'ici la fin de l'année 2022
et puis là-dessus est arrivé l'Ukraine
et d'autre part est-ce que c'est juste
un choc sur les coups
sur l'offre pour employer le terme
économique ou est-ce que c'est quelque
chose qui se diffuse plus largement et
je crois que là-dessus évidemment
l'invasion russe de l'Ukraine a entraîné
le fait qu'un choc temporaire est devenu
durable et je ne vous cache pas que
notre inquiétude collective la mienne
personnelle c'est beaucoup accru au
printemps dernier quand nous avons vu
qu'il y avait un phénomène de diffusion
c'est pour ça que j'ai beaucoup insisté
dans mon propos introductif sur
l'inflation sous-jacente c'est à dire or
énergie et matières premières pour
prendre l'exemple des services les
services sont peu touchés par le choc
énergétique et pourtant l'inflation des
services s'est accéléré donc je crois
qu'il s'est passé quelque chose dans
l'économie dans la psychologie
collective qui fait que l'inflation qui
avait été effectivement oubliée est
revenu dans les comportements y compris
de fixation des prix c'est ça qui
justifie la réaction de la politique
monétaire je reviendrai à la question du
président alors sur les trois questions
plus spécifiques que vous avez posées à
propos de l'immobilier
a effectivement nous prévoyons un recul
limité de l'investissement des ménages
enfin des acquisitions immobilières mais
après des années exceptionnellement
favorable
c'est pour ça que j'ai cité
une moyenne de longues périodes si vous
rapportez le taux de 1,9 % que j'ai cité
en novembre il se compare à une moyenne
de longues périodes de 3% sur les 20
dernières années on a un peu oublié ces
références mais c'est plutôt ça la
normalité pour vous donner une autre
illustration si je regarde la production
de nouveaux crédits immobiliers elle
était en 2015 de 120 milliards d'euros
considère que ça c'est peut-être une
année à peu près normale ou de référence
et elle a constamment accéléré au cours
de ces années de Toba puisqu’en 2022 on
a maintenant le chiffre elle est 220
milliards d'euros donc presque le double
alors même qu'on a vu un début de
normalisation en fin d'année donc c'est
vrai qu'il va y avoir une petite baisse
mais c'est par rapport à des niveaux qui
étaient
finalement élevé vous avez posé la
question du taux de l'usure alors c'est
un débat qui effectivement a fait couler
beaucoup d'encre
là nous considérons que le rôle de la
Banque de France est modeste mais
essentiel c'est d'appliquer la loi
je le dis ici
avec beaucoup de gravité la loi dit en
la matière la chose suivante c'est que
le taux de l'usure dont je rappelle
qu'il est destiné à protéger les
emprunteurs contre des taux anormalement
élevés on a beaucoup entendu les
prêteurs dans ce débat on n'a pas
beaucoup entendu les emprunteurs mais
nous nous sommes là pour être à l'écoute
de tous et pour faire appliquer la loi
la loi dit que ce taux de l'usure est
fixé trimestriellement à quatre tiers
des taux observés dans le trimestre
précédent c'est au fond assez simple et
notre rôle est de calculer
c'est vrai que j'ai subi beaucoup de
pression de la part de représentants des
prêteurs d'hiver que je ne nommerai pas
pour dire il faut remonter plus vite le
taux de l'usure
je ne crois pas que ce soit souhaitable
voilà je le dis très simplement parce
que c'est la loi et parce qu'il faut une
remontée progressive ordonnée pour
protéger les emprunteurs ce qui est en
question aujourd'hui vous avez fait
légitimement allusion monsieur le
rapporteur général c'est un éventuel
ajustement technique c'est-à-dire au
lieu de faire cette ajustement une fois
en fin de trimestre avec une grosse
marche puisque nous avons remonté le
taux de l'usure en gros de 0,5%, fin
septembre puis fin décembre on ferait
trois plus petites marches moi par mois
en regardant les trois mois précédents à
chaque fois c'est un ajustement
technique je considère qu'il peut être
justifié si il est souhaité par les
professionnels du crédit que nous
consulterons
à cet égard si c'est un progrès
collectif je crois qu'on est tout à fait
dans l'esprit de la loi
sur l'emploi alors j'avoue que j'ai pas
regardé précisément les précisions du
gouvernement ce que je veux simplement
relever ça c'est plutôt une bonne
nouvelle de l'école française et
européenne en général c'est que j'ai dit
que l'activité nous avait parfois
surpris en bien mais l'emploi nous a
toujours surpris en bien depuis 3 ans
l'emploi résiste beaucoup mieux que
l'activité économique je vous cite des
chiffres parce qu'ils sont assez
frappants en 2020 alors il y avait eu
une baisse d'emploi en 2020 bien sûr
avec le choc covid mais en 2021
l'économie française a fait plus que
rattraper les baisses de 2020
puisqu'elle a créé 840 000 emplois c'est
un chiffre qu'on n'avait pas vu depuis
très longtemps sur un an et en 2022 ça
c'est un peu ralenti l'économie est un
peu moins dynamique mais on est quand
même à 300 000 emplois créés sur les
trois premiers trimestres donc c'est
vrai qu'avec la croissance très
faiblement positive de 2023 on prévoit
une légère remontée du chômage mais mais
assez limité je n'exclus pas que là nous
ne trompions un peu par le bas parce que
nous avons toujours eu des surprises par
le haut
reste la question de l'euro numérique
mériterait de longs développements en
soi et je vais simplement dire où nous
en sommes au sein de l'euro-système
et pourquoi est-ce que nous conseillons
ce qui est un projet donc c'est un
projet qui a été lancé autour de
Christina garde avec un prototype qui
est aujourd'hui étudié dont nous tirons
les leçons fin 2023 début 2024 donc
d'ici un an en gros et si nous décidions
je souligne le si une généralisation il
faudrait encore trois ans environ donc
fin 2026 début 2027 pourquoi est-ce que
nous regardons ceci parce que il y a un
certain nombre d'innovations dans le
champ des paiements et de la monnaie
alors c'est la blockchain c'est la
possibilité d'échanger à la fois des
flux d'argent mais aussi des données et
des informations associées et sans
rentrer dans les détails comme nous le
savons tous ces innovations sont
aujourd'hui purement portées par des
acteurs privés c'est les fameux crypto
et là je parle pas du Bitcoin avant tout
spéculatif mais souvenez-vous du projet
de Libra de facebook aujourd'hui
abandonné mais qui peut revenir de la
part d'autres acteurs bon et de toute
une série d'acteurs privés qui disent
moi j'ai moyen que vous échangiez à la
fois des flux de paiement et grâce à des
technologies numériques des données à
cecies il nous semble que ce potentiel
est prometteur y compris pour les
particuliers et que dans la tradition de
la monnaie a toujours un partenariat
entre public et privé on n'a jamais
laissé le monopole des innovations sur
la monnaie aux acteurs privés et là il y
a un enjeu démocratique mais un peu dans
l'autre sens je prends tout à fait au
sérieux la question sur les données
privées mais l'idée que nous prions les
citoyens d'innovation technologiques
importantes associées à de la monnaie
publique souveraine avec toutes ces
caractéristiques de solidité et et très
je crois regrettable en tout cas mérite
l'étude les citoyens ne se rend pas
condamné à de la monnaie privée pour
avoir les meilleures innovations
technologiques après il y a un certain
nombre de questions sur le comment tout
à fait légitime je voudrais rassurer les
représentants de la nation et puis les
professionnels il ne s'agit absolument
pas de désintermédié les banques je sais
que
certains titres de la presse
internationale en mal de sensations
antitressa c'est faux c'est faux d'abord
parce que les encours de cette euro
numérique serait probablement plafonné
limité il s'agit pas de vider les
comptes bancaires
ensuite parce qu'il serait très
probablement distribué par les banques
et nous n'avons nous avons arrêté à la
Banque de France d'avoir des comptes de
particuliers en 2004 nous n'avons aucune
intention de recommencer ce qui est
peut-être une dernière réponse à la
question sur la protection de la vie
privée que vous posiez et qui est
évidemment clé il s'agit pas que la
banque centrale puisse avoir accès à des
données sur les citoyens encore moins à
leur programmation de dépenses peut-être
dernière précision mais vous comprenez
bien qu'à nos juste une question ouverte
mais j'ai essayé de dire pourquoi je me
méfie toujours de l'idée que le monopole
de l'innovation est réservé aux acteurs
privés et tout à fait entre nous ces
acteurs privés ne sont pas européen j'ai
pas besoin de nommer les émetteurs
possibles de crypto où les big tech mais
si nous allions vers le Rhône numérique
je suis une encore une fois le si il ne
s'agit en aucun cas de supprimer les
espèces
la Banque de France n'abandonnera jamais
les espèces la production et la
distribution des billets ça doit être un
libre choix de nos concitoyens et moi on
me demande souvent mais quelle forme de
moyens de paiement vous préférez est-ce
que vous poussez le billet les cartes un
jour l'euro numérique la réponse est
simple nous nous sommes là pour garantir
la liberté de choix de nos concitoyens
s'il y a diverses formes de moyens de
paiement ça fait partie de la confiance
de la monnaie ils doivent être tous
égales accessibilité vous êtes battus
beaucoup pour ça monsieur le rapporteur
général des gale qualité légale sécurité
merci on va démarrer profiterez
profiteur des réponses pour répondre
également à ma question à ma question
j'ai le droit à 30 secondes là-dessus
non non parce que votre question était
très importante allez une minute d'abord
je vous confirme qu'il y a des
discussions au sein du Conseil du
gouverneur et si j'allais dire
heureusement parce que il m'arrive de
dire si nous n'avions aucune discussion
du conseil général ça serait pas la
peine qu'il existe d'aller à Francfort
après alors elle est traditionnellement
décrit en terre mornithologique il y
aurait les faucons et les colombes
j'aime pas beaucoup cette discussion je
conseille je ne suis pas un oiseau dans
cette qualification et moi je me décris
toujours comme un pragmatique
c'est-à-dire je ne crois pas qu'il faut
que nous ayons de position déterminée à
l'avance il y a ceux qui sont toujours
partisans de monter les taux d'intérêt
et ce jamais
il y a peut-être certains membres du
Conseil des gouverneurs qui se
rapprochent un peu plus de cette
caricature je viens d'évoquer ils sont
plus prévisibles moi je crois que ça
dépend des données enfin ce que disait
le rapporteur général est absolument
vrai sur l'évolution de l'inflation
depuis 18 mois je crois que relever les
taux fins 2021 alors qu'on ne savait pas
compenser que c'était peut-être
temporairement l'offre ça aurait été une
erreur parce qu'à l'époque on ne savait
pas hein aujourd'hui ne pas les relever
alors que nous avons une inflation qui
menace de s'installer je pense que ça
serait grave maintenant je ne vous dirai
pas monsieur le Président jusqu'à quel
niveau parce que je ne le sais pas moi
j'ai pas de site prédéterminé ça aussi
pragmatisme on a dû remonter très vite
au deuxième semestre de l'année dernière
et je crois que c'était justifié parce
qu'on sortait d'une situation où il est
pas assez d'inflation évitée à déflation
donc il y avait des taux très bas les
fameux taux négatifs fallait sortir de
ça très vite à 2% on est à peu près à ce
que les économistes appellent le tour
neutre il faudra sans doute aller
au-delà pour freiner l'inflation sans
provoquer de récession ça je crois
pouvoir dire aujourd'hui qu'il n'y aura
pas de récession de l'économie française
et européenne en 2023 mais nous verrons
dans les prochains mois
merci Monsieur le Gouverneur donc
commençons nos questions avec Hervé
Moret et Pascal Savoldelli
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
Joël d'abord
que je me réjouis de ses propos à
l'occasion de ses vœux concernant la
nécessité de mieux encadrer les acteurs
des crypto actifs puisque comme vous le
savez certainement le Sénat sur la
proposition de notre commission à voter
à dispositif en ce sens dans le cadre du
projet de loi portant divers
dispositions d'adaptation droit de
l'Union européenne vos propos vont dans
le sens de de ce tenu par la présidente
de l'AMF fier et j'espère qu'ils
inspireront le gouvernement et
l'Assemblée nationale puisque le texte
qu'on a adopté va venir à l'Assemblée
nationale à la fin de à la fin de ce
mois je voudrais vous interroger sur
trois petits sujets qui concernent sur
tous les épargnants et les consommateurs
le l'Observatoire de la sécurité des
moyens de paiement à souligner récemment
une augmentation des fraudes bancaires
et les associations de consommateurs
soulignent régulièrement la difficulté
qu'elles ont à obtenir
de la part des banques un remboursement
de ces fraudes est-ce que c'est un sujet
qui est dans votre viseur est-ce qu'il y
a des des moyens de d'améliorer les
choses c'est ma première question la
deuxième concerne les frais bancaires de
succession j'avais
interpellé le Ministre de l'économie
dans une question écrite il y a
maintenant plusieurs mois il m'avait
répondu qu'une réunion du comité
consultatif du secteur financier dans
vos assurés le secrétariat avait prévu
de lancer des travaux en septembre 2022
vu d'ici je n'ai rien vu est-ce que les
choses avancent vraiment et surtout
comme j'ai l'impression que c'est pas
tellement le cas pourquoi elle n'avance
pas davantage j'ai déposé une
proposition de loi en ce sens et je
pense que je la transformerai en
amendement la proposition de loi de
Monsieur Husson donc quelle est la
dessus votre votre position et dernière
dernière question pour pas être plus
long on observe régulièrement une baisse
de la capacité d'accéder à la monnaie
c'est-à-dire en fait une un nombre de
fermetures des dabs qui ne fait
qu'augmenter qui est de plus en plus
préoccupant et pas seulement amélior
rural y compris dans les dans les
petites villes donc par rapport à cette
situation puisque vous allez rappeler
l'importance que chacun puisse disposer
des moyens de paiement de son choix
comment peut-on freiner ce cet évolution
tout à fait retable je vous remercie
merci Hervé Pascal symbole d'élite puis
Daniel Bruyer
si monsieur le Président
merci aussi à vous Monsieur le
Gouverneur pour votre votre présentation
qui est toujours la même la qualité de
la clarté
et argumenter je vais vous poser deux
questions sur le gouverneur une première
qui avait été déjà relayée mais le
président me dira si j'ai bien compris
c'est ce que vous avez évoqué vous dans
votre propos liminaire vous avez dit la
surprise du mal l'inflation et le
président renna l'a posé la question de
la remontée des taux
moi je vous avoue que je suis préoccupé
par cette situation parce que
on a une crise qui impose à la fois un
déploiement accéléré des énergies
renouvelables et des solutions qui
permettent de réduire la consommation
d'énergie
ça je pense que Don tact ça ça rassemble
tout le monde et d'un côté on la les
hausses des taux qui sont successivement
décidées par la Banque de France et la
banque européenne pour lutter contre
l'inflation vous nous l'avez dit mais
aussi qui rend chérissent le coup de
financement des solutions je pense que
ça ça va et donc moi la question que je
vous pose c'est ce qu'il faut mobiliser
des des outils politiques monétaires
lesquels je ne suis pas spécialiste un
gens convient Monsieur le Gouverneur
pour protéger le déploiement des
solutions sinon on n'aura pas les
solutions puisqu'elles sont trop
coûteuses donc je vois là je voulais
vous poser ça entre la concordance et
entre la hausse des taux directeurs de
la BCE et les solutions à la crise
énergétique et climatique ma deuxième
question
j'ai entendu par la voix du ministre le
maire que livret de développement
durable et solidaire n'a de verres que
le nom c'est lui qui a dit ça
bon
ma question est-ce vrai mais je vous
demande pas de répondre seulement au
ministre maire je vois bien l'inconfort
que ça peut vous poser moi je vous pose
la question suivante et estimez-vous
qu'il est opportun aujourd'hui de
modifier les règles de mobilisation la
fraction bancaire du livret de
développement durable et solidaire ou
bien celles centralisée par la Caisse
des Dépôts là il y a un choix en tout
cas qui intéresse aussi nos concitoyens
et que la transition écologique
éventuellement une de ses pauvreté
prérogatives serait la rénovation
énergétique la rénovation thermique des
bâtiments et est-ce qu'on a besoin d'un
produit d'épargne de plus voilà je vous
pose la question est-ce qu'il en faut un
de plus
et qui pour moi aujourd'hui mais vous
pouvez me rassurer est-ce qu'il est pas
à un nouvel outil qui serait un outil de
risque et moins liquide que ce qui
existe actuellement merci
merci Pascal Daniel Bruyer puis Michel
Cannet ma question rejoint au fond les
préoccupations bien d'exprimer Pascal
Savoldelli les équipes de la BCE ont
souligné l'importance de la transition
écologique sur le sur le maintien et la
stabilité des prix
en fait j'aimerais savoir dans cette
période où les difficultés énergétiques
nourrissent quand même l'inflation et en
ont été un des déclencheurs et pèse très
lourdement sur les ménages sur les
entreprises et sur les capacités des
collectivités à investir dans la
transition écologique quelles
conséquences vous tirez au niveau de la
BCE et de la Banque de France dans ce
contexte pour soutenir cette nécessaire
transition énergétique
merci Daniel Michel canvett depuis
Christian BIAC si Michel le Président
Monsieur le Gouverneur quand je vous
écoute j'ai un peu le sentiment que vous
souhaitez brider le développement du
crédit immobilier dans notre pays c'est
aussi un peu le ressenti que j'ai
entendre un certain nombre de
responsables publics or je suis de ceux
qui considère que au contraire nous
avons besoin d'aller beaucoup plus loin
dans le crédit immobilier puisque nous
avons de réels problèmes de logement
dans notre pays auquel il faut apporter
des réponses et je n'ai pas le sentiment
que cela puisse être apporté uniquement
par les investissements publics on voit
bien dans un contexte de renchérissement
du taux du livret A et donc des
conséquences sur le niveau des du coup
des prêts aux opérateurs publics la
difficulté aussi à mobiliser les
entrepreneurs du bâtiment et puis donc
se mobiliser les opérations et je
voulais vous demander s'il ne fallait
pas au contraire continuer à faire
confiance aux épargnants au secteur
privé pour pouvoir répondre au défi du
logement dans notre pays et à l'instar
de ce qui évoquait à l'instant Pascal ça
vole des lits peut-être aussi de
reconsidérer les outils qui existent à
cet égard il y a un certain nombre de
livrer le livret A le livret de
développement durable le livret rose les
livrets d'épargne logement le plan
d'épargne logement est-ce qu'il ne
faudrait pas reconsidérer tout cela à
refendre tout cela et avoir un
dispositif qui soit un peu plus adapté
face aux défis auquel nous sommes
affrontés c'est un premier sujet un
second concerne la situation économique
avec un certain nombre d'inquiétudes
quand même devant nous puisque nous
voyons bien la hausse des prix apporte
un renchérissement du coût des des
produits et donc des difficultés pour
les entreprises et des coûts de
l'énergie en particulier affecte
significativement la productivité des
entreprises
n'est-ce pas un signe de risque de
récession en même temps qu'un certain
nombre de
projets sur la table actuellement je
vais parler par exemple du régime
d'erreurs enfin de la réforme des
retraites risque d'amener des
perturbations dans
la vie de notre pays est-ce que cela ne
risque pas d'avoir un impact
significatif sur le niveau de de
l'activité l'évolution du PIB pour
l'année 2023 et puis dernière question
les
politiques publiques ont beaucoup fait
beaucoup recouru à l'entraînement ces
dernières années est-ce que cela ne
risque pas d'être particulièrement
dramatique pour
les budgets publics je veux dire par là
que la hausse des taux d'intérêt risque
de plomber significativement les budgets
publics est-ce que cela n'est pas un
risque majeur pour la stabilité
financière et la sécurité financière de
notre pays
merci Michel Christian BIAT depuis
Vincent Delahaye
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
gouverneur vous avez évoqué les taux
immobiliers
moi je voudrais vous poser une question
parce que comme tout mes collègues ici
je rencontre fréquemment les maires et
certains me demandent mon avis sur la
conduite à tenir en matière financière
au sujet de l'endettement en particulier
et donc vous avez annoncé une hausse des
taux d'intérêt à venir certainement dans
l'année 2023 est-ce qu'on peut penser
que les taux vont redescendre peut-être
pas au niveau qu'ils étaient auparavant
mais enfin est-ce que c'est tout peuvent
redescendre et est-ce qu'il est
préférable pour les collectivités de ce
at au niveau de l'endettement de l'or
qu'ils ont les marges ce domaine qui ne
sont pas surendettés elle connaît la
collectivités ont intérêt
de financer dès maintenant par empereur
leur budget ou est-ce qu'il est
préférable d'attendre d'être au meilleur
puisque vous annoncez parallèlement
une baisse de l'inflation donc prenait
aussi une belle étoile d'intérêt sur
2024 voilà donc
qu'est-ce que je pourrais prendre dans
ce maire souvent des mers ruraux qui ne
sont pas des spécialistes financiers et
qui se tournent vers moi ou vers mes
collègues pour dire qu'est-ce que je
peux faire en matière d'endettement
merci Christian Vincent Delahaye puis
manuel Capu merci monsieur le Président
oui Monsieur le Gouverneur une question
très simple vous avez dû tout à l'heure
que les outils de luttent contre
l'inflation n'était pas budgétaire donc
je partage mais qu'ils étaient
monétaires et structurels alors
monétaire je comprends parfaitement
structurel je sais pas trop ce que c'est
donc si vous pouviez m'expliquer un
petit peu ces outils structurels ça
m'intéresse
question courte
merci merci Vincent donc Emmanuel Capu
puis Sylvie vermillier merci monsieur le
Président moi j'ai trois questions la
première a été un petit peu abordée par
Michel canvez c'est celle du risque de
récession vous nous avez dit que vous
étiez assez confiant pour le moment je
crois vous avez dit sur ce risque de
récession en France pourtant c'est vrai
que les
la Banque mondiale est assez inquiète et
nous dit quand même que dans 95% des
États du monde
les prévisions sont des seront dégradées
et il y a une dégradation importante des
prévisions donc comment est-ce que votre
analyse se s'articule avec celle de la
Banque mondiale ça c'était ma première
question la deuxième question
porte sur la productivité des
entreprises vous nous avez dit également
que vous n'êtes pas inquiet sur la
capacité de remboursement notamment des
PGE par les entreprises françaises
compte tenu de leur solvabilité mais ne
craignez-vous pas que cela impacte pour
le coup leur capacité d'investissement
comme pour les collectivités
territoriales d'ailleurs et est-ce que
vous avez un outil d'analyse sur cette
dégradation éventuelle de la
productivité de nos entreprises qui
doivent faire face à une augmentation du
crédit et remboursement des prêts qu'ils
ont contractés par le passé et la
troisième question très rapide vous avez
parlé du taux d'usure que pensez-vous du
taux d'usure vert
très simple
donc du taux d'intro d'usure
différentielle pour favoriser la
notamment la rénovation énergétique
c'est une demande qui est formulée par
certains
merci Emmanuel Sylvie vermeiller puis
Gérard Longuet
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Gouverneur je voudrais apporter à
aborder deux sujets
premiers compte tenu de du contexte
mondial de l'inflation du coût de
l'énergie quel est le regard de la
Banque de France sur l'enjeu du Zéro
artificialisation nette est-ce que pour
vous c'est pas un enjeu contradictoire
avec
le développement nécessaire qui devient
contraint aujourd'hui et deuxième
question en tant que rapporteur spécial
des régimes sociaux et de retraite
comment est-ce que vous abordez la fin
du régime spécial Banque de France il y
a deux ans Laurent pietrazevski
déclarait que le régime spécial Banque
de France perdurerait il me semble que
les salariés de la Banque de France
avaient consenti à des efforts ou
salariaux au profit de la caisse de
réserve
des employés comment est-ce que vous
abordez cette cette annonce d'hier avec
la fin du régime Banque de France merci
merci Sylvie genre Longuet donc suivi de
Vincent capo Cana
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Gouverneur les 30 dernières années ont
été marqué par des une inflation réduite
liée à la mondialisation si l'on accepte
la crise de 2008 où nous avons eu en
effet une montée très forte des taux
d'intérêt mais les taux d'intérêt ont
été en Europe et en France plutôt
modeste en raison de cette certitude
d'une maîtrise des prix par la
concurrence internationale pensez-vous
que c'est pour ces 20 ou 30 prochaines
années la perspective d'une
décarbonation énergique conduite par les
nations responsables ne va pas aboutir
nécessairement à une inflation en
donnant de la valeur
à des investissements dont la
productivité est indispensable certes
à l'harmonie climatique mais qui
représente un coup sans présenter
nécessairement une production
merci Gérard
Vincent kapokanella puis Eric Bocquet
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
gouverneur dans votre propos on le
comprend il y a naturellement et
fonctionnellement si tu es en direct une
part de confiance si on se relative une
part de vigilance peut-être que nous on
devrait dire de d'inquiétude en essayant
de décrypter vos propos alors confiance
en nous sur l'activité sur l'objectif
vous nous dites à porter de réduction
d'inflation et puis vigilance ou
inquiétude sur la dette sans doute alors
la question qu'on peut se poser
peut-être c'est celle de la fin qu'on
doit se poser plutôt c'est celle de la
soutenabilité de l'augmentation des taux
et ne devrions-nous pas collectivement
et peut-être que la Banque de France ne
devrait-elle peut-être pas être plus
actif plus insistante sur les risques
que nous courons aujourd'hui sur
l'alerte comment concilier
l'augmentation des taux et la situation
propre des finances publiques françaises
alors là dessus on est sans doute un peu
dans une situation compliquée en Europe
et sans doute que vous voulez être dans
le conseil des gouverneurs pour ce qui
nous concerne
première question deuxième question le
scénario d'une quantité de travail
supplémentaire d'une augmentation de la
quantité du travail vous paraît-il de
nature à permettre était suffisant pour
permettre de sortir de cette spirale là
est-ce que ça va être le remède vous
nous avez certifié qu'il fallait c'est
le contenir les dépenses courantes mais
est-ce que vous croyez à ce scénario que
nous avons souvent nous disons tout va
se régler avec une augmentation de la
quantité de travail
merci Vincent
Eric Bocquet puis Patrice joli oui merci
monsieur le Président merci Monsieur le
Gouverneur pour vos propos introductifs
une première question sur vous avez
évoqué le sujet des crypto monnaie il en
était beaucoup question ces dernières
semaines avec l'effondrement de la
plateforme FTX aux États-Unis
j'ai cru comprendre que vous appeliez de
votre côté à une plus grande régulation
de ce type d'activité alors est-ce que
vous considérez que c'est un accident de
parcours des pif phénomènes ou un
problème beaucoup plus profond qui
nécessiterait qu'on l'appréhende de
manière politique au sens large une
entreprise partie de rien qui a très
vite atteint un niveau de capitalisation
boursière de 3000 milliards de dollars
bon une vraie question donc avec tous
les risques que ça peut générer la
deuxième question c'est sur la dette
souveraine
avec sa politique de rachat de d'actifs
de dettes des États à l'Union la Banque
centrale européenne détenez enfin je
crois savoir mais vous confirmerez c'est
pour ça que je vais vous interroger
là-dessus entre 20 et 25% de la dette
française et bien cela alors ma question
la suivante comment cette dette comment
Banque de France oui comment cette dette
va être gérée au niveau de la blessure
par rapport à nous l'étain et
autres phénomène qu'on avait observé au
plus fort de la crise covid on avait
constaté que l'épargne des Français
enfin tout cas de ceux qui peuvent
épargner avait augmenté de manière
sensible pour des raisons évidentes de
non consommation à la fin la dénom 2020
2021 et je crois qu'on avait atteint un
chiffre de 150 milliards supplémentaires
voilà vous confirmer ce chiffre et ça
m'amène à réfléchir un peu au
financement de la dette d'un état et je
pense notamment à la situation des
Japonais qui n'a rien de comparable à
nous mais quand même qui fait réfléchir
la dette japonaise elle est à 250% du
PIB du Japon mais elle est détenue à 85%
par des investisseurs japonais
institutions et particulier aussi alors
est-ce que cette épargne des Français ne
pourrait pas être l'occasion d'imaginer
un autre type de financement d'un État
comme le nôtre en tout cas pour une
partie de manière à se défaire un peu de
l'emprise des marchés financiers qui
financent allègrement notre dette
puisque nous allons emprunter cette
année 270 milliards d'euros comme vous
le savez merci
merci Eric alors Laurent en pensant à
FTX parti de rien pensez toujours à
cette histoire partie de rien arrivé à
rien mais tout seul
des choses bon voilà
alors Patrice joli puis Victorin Lurel
Fabien merci monsieur le Président merci
Monsieur le Gouverneur pour votre
intervention luminaire
deux sujets le premier on est souvent
très attentifs à l'endettement public en
tout cas dans le débat public c'est
généralement ce qui est le plus souvent
évoqué un peu moins au regard sur
l'endettement privé et deux questions
avez-vous une idée des risques de
défaillance s'agissant de de
l'endettement des ménages regarde
l'évolution notamment du coup de
l'argent et donc de la tête des ménages
et puis s'agissant des entreprises
ça a été un peu évoqué précédemment
aujourd'hui
les entreprises français sont
globalement plus endettés que les
entreprises des pays occidentaux
regardent des besoins
d'investissement qui ont été réalisés
qui ont été qui sont nécessaires et qui
ont déjà été évoquées pensez-vous qu'il
y a ou des difficultés à réaliser ses
investissements ou des risques
complémentaires que pourraient qui
pourrait concerner les entreprises
françaises au regard de l'évolution du
coût de l'argent c'est le premier point
le deuxième concerne le taux d'usure
aujourd'hui des établissements
financiers considèrent que le taux
d'usure est insuffisant ce qui les
conduit à être beaucoup plus réceptif en
matière de crédit et donc ce qui génère
des difficultés d'accès au crédit pour
les PME parce qu'elles sont obligées
d'avoir des apports plus importants ou
des garanties accrues et donc
pensez-vous que c'est une difficulté
au regard des en tout cas sur le plan de
la croissance des entreprises et de leur
capacités à investir améliorer leur
productivité et surtout à faire face
s'investissement de transition qu'elles
devront réaliser merci merci
puis philippe Dominati
monsieur le Président c'est juste une
demande d'éclairage sur les parents
populaires et en particulier sur les
plans et les comptes et parents
logements et j'aimerais savoir quelle
est la situation aujourd'hui des pelles
souscrit jusqu'au 28 février 2011 est-ce
que la formulation grec c'est bien
toujours 70% du choix plus la différence
entre les swap de 10 et 2 ans quel est
aujourd'hui la situation de CPL d'avant
2011 enfin 28 février 2011
merci Victorin philippe Dominati puis
Rémy Ferro qui conclut les questions sur
le garage je profite de votre présence
parce que vous êtes à la fois un acteur
mais surtout un observateur dans le
match concernant la préverie site et la
place financière de Paris
j'aimerais savoir si vous pensez que
nous avons progressé nous sommes sur une
dynamique par rapport aux autres places
européennes Amsterdam Francfort et quels
sont éventuellement les institutions qui
ont pris siègent dans
le Bassin parisien et éventuellement
est-ce qu'il y a des éléments nouveaux
qui sont en perspective je pense
peut-être à des chambres de compensation
ou à des organismes tels que cela qui
sont
dont on ne sait pas véritablement s'ils
sont essentiels et à quoi ils servent en
tout cas à mon niveau mais je voudrais
savoir s'il y a des perspectives en
conjonction avec le Gouvernement sur ce
sujet là
merci Philippe Rémy Ferro
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Gouverneur merci pour votre exposé de
départ qui pour nous est quand même très
éclairant par rapport au budget que nous
avons voté juste avant les vacances
parce que l'hypothèse de croissance
n'est pas la même que celle du budget je
pense pas que vous pourrez nous en dire
beaucoup plus que ce que vous nous avez
dit à ce stade mais c'est pour quand
même un souci d'inquiétude c'est un
sujet d'inquiétude pardon surtout je
crois que le ministre de l'économie à ce
matin Isabelle musique confirmé lui
l'hypothèse de croissance de 1% du
gouvernement alors est-ce que vous
pouvez nous dire c'est possible quels
sont les différences d'hypothèses qui
conduites à cette différence en dehors
d'une forme de volontarisme du
gouvernement afin de ne pas avoir
d'hypothèse qui soit trop peu
auto-réalisatrice mais est-ce qu'il y a
des éléments objectifs qui conduisent à
cette différence de prévision et 0,3% on
n'est pas en récession bien sûr mais on
peut y bas assez vite on en est pas très
loin on est quand même proche d'une
croissance zéro donc c'est vrai que
votre volonté d'équilibre sur
l'augmentation des taux d'intérêt donc
vous pouvez bien sûr pas nous dire le
niveau etc et tout à fait compréhensible
mais
quelle est la marge de manœuvre dans
l'année pour revoir cette équilibre
parce que
finalement le but est de d'avoir une
politique monétaire pour lutter contre
l'inflation et vos recommandations c'est
surtout que la politique budgétaire le
fasse le moins possible enfin ça peut
conduire aussi à une augmentation quand
même du déficit il n'y a pas tellement
d'éléments dans le dans le budget pour
lutter en 2023 contre l'inflation il
peut aussi y avoir besoin du coup de
politique budgétaire pour soutenir la
croissance bref c'est un équilibre
fragile dans une période qui est
difficile qu'elle comment voyez-vous
aussi la capacité de s'adapter à
l'évolution de la situation au cours de
l'année 2023
c'était le mot de la fin si je puis dire
ce gouverneur c'est bien vous avez de
quoi refaire un exposé magistral
je sais pas si il sera magistral mais je
voulais voir avec vous de bon je salue
la qualité de toutes les questions je
vais voir avec vous monsieur le
Président combien de temps nous avons
parce que à des fois d'être magistral je
veux pas être trop long
franchement une trentaine de minutes on
reçoit une fois par an d'accord je suis
tout prêt à venir plus souvent si vous
voulez nous pourrions d'ailleurs si vous
me permettez de glisser renouer avec ce
qui a été parfois une tradition c'était
le sénateur Colin dans mon souvenir qui
était attaché qui est que la commission
des finances en tout cas les membres qui
le souhaitent viennent aussi une fois de
temps en temps à la Banque de France
c'est un bien qui vous appartient et qui
n'est pas aussi beau que le Palais du
Luxembourg mais presque mais je me
demande si chez Yvon Colin il y avait
pas aussi le goût de la table voyez mais
la table ne sait pas trop dégradée alors
je vais je vais essayer et vos questions
permettent je crois de revenir sur
beaucoup de sujets évidemment essentiels
pour nos concitoyens d'abord sur la
question du sénateur Moret
il a dû nous quitter mais voulu
transmettrez un vibrant soutien à sa
proposition de réglementation des crypto
actifs je crois je crois avoir été le
premier le dire et je donne une pression
technique
je le dis d'ailleurs
par rapport je crois au sénateur Bocquet
j'ai souvent des points d'accord mais
vous avez parlé de crypto monnaie j'aime
pas ce terme pour des raisons évidentes
ça n'a rien d'une monnaie crypto actif
il se trouve que la réglementation
française la loi pacte et qui à l'époque
était un progrès parce que nous avons
été parmi les premiers à prévoir un
statut le statut dit de psan prestataire
de service en acteur numérique en actif
numérique pardon et elle prévoit
aujourd'hui deux possibilités il y a une
possibilité de simple enregistrement
vous nous contrôlons quand même la lutte
anti blanchiment et puis il y a une
possibilité d'agrément donc la
proposition qui est faite et que je
soutiens totalement aujourd'hui c'est
que l'agrément devienne obligatoire le
plus rapidement possible d'ici la fin de
l'année sur les autres questions sur les
fraudes bancaires et leur remboursement
c'est effectivement un sujet très
sensible au sein de l'Observatoire sur
la sécurité moyennement que je préside
je rappelle la règle nous l'avons
rappelé aux banques la règle c'est le
remboursement l'exception
en cas de fraude l'exception c'est le
non remboursement s'il y a présomption
sérieuse voilà d'une relative complicité
mauvaise foi etc de la part du payeur
bon c'est des sujets qu'il faut prendre
au sérieux qui sont pas simples mais je
me permets de rappeler la règle et le
principe et il faut effectivement
globalement que ça soit remboursé plus
vite sur les frais de succession vous me
permettrez de regarder parce que je suis
conscient que c'est un sujet sensible je
ne l'était pas à vrai dire que les
travaux du CCSF n'avançaient pas aussi
vite que prévu donc là je vais un peu
sonner l'alerte
sur la capacité d'accès à la monnaie en
particulier au billets sujet qui est
aussi très cher au rapporteur général et
à nous
nous publions chaque année au mois de
juillet une étude là-dessus et le taux
d'accès de nos concitoyens aux dab est
aujourd'hui maintenu je vous cite juste
un chiffre il y a un peu moins de dab
c'est vrai mais 99% de nos concitoyens
habitent à moins d'un quart d'heure d'un
distributeur automatique de billets
pourquoi est-ce que le nombre de dabs
diminue objectivement ça coûte cher pour
les banques et la diminution se
concentre dans les villes aujourd'hui
nous sommes extrêmement attentifs et je
sais que leur apporteur général l'est au
maintien de la couverture territoriale
voilà jusqu'à présent notamment des
opérations de regroupement qui ont pu
avoir lieu entre certains réseaux
bancaires ne paraissent plutôt
intelligentes parce qu'elles
maintiennent la capacité de distribution
tout en permettant de gérer les frais
là-dessus mais il s'agit absolument pas
de diminuer d'accessibilité notamment en
milieu rural
sur la question de Monsieur salvadelli
sur la hausse des taux et le le
financement des solutions énergétiques
plusieurs autres sénateurs y sont
revenus
la hausse des tours je crois qu'elle est
absolument nécessaire pour lutter contre
l'inflation je vais pas le répéter je
redis avec beaucoup de convictions et
j'espère partager que il y a pas à
choisir entre la lutte contre
l'inflation et la croissance je sais que
cette idée existe souvent mais si nous
laissons s'installer l'inflation c'est
le pire ennemi de la croissance dans la
durée parce que un c'est un ennemi de la
confiance plusieurs d'entre vous
parlaient des investissements des
entreprises pour un chef d'entreprise
c'est très difficile de prévoir des
investissements quand c'est incertitude
sur l'évolution des prix et la valeur de
la monnaie donc il faut de la confiance
et des repères sur la valeur de la
monnaie et l'autre raison c'est que si
on laisse s'installer l'inflation modèle
des années 70 ça nous amènera à la
question historique de Gérard Longuet
si nous laissons s'installer l'inflation
à ce moment-là il faudra en remettre de
cheval pour la faire sortir le remède de
cheval certains d'entre nous s'en
souviennent c'est Monsieur Walker aux
États-Unis qui remonte les taux
d'intérêt lui il est pas au-dessus de 2%
comme nous allons être il est au-dessus
de 20 % et lui provoque une récession
forte aux États-Unis donc c'est cette
arbitrage inflation croissance ne joue
que dans des situations très graves que
notre action a précisément pourvu
d'éviter sur le financement des
solutions
des transitions énergétiques et j'y
reviendrai à propos d'autres questions
sur l'investissement des entreprises
je crois que nous devons mieux organiser
le financement européen j'ai parlé
rapidement à la fin de mon propos d'une
union verte des marchés de capitaux je
ne veux pas ennuyer la commission des
finances avec les dispositions
techniques de l'Union des marchés de
capitaux mais objectivement c'est un
sujet où nous avons beaucoup d'épargne
disponibles en Europe beaucoup de
besoins de financement en face et nous
n'arrivons pas à mettre ses ressources
en face de ses besoins parce que il y a
des marchés qui sont beaucoup trop
cloisonnés l'épargne dans certains pays
les besoins sont dans d'autres là il
faut vraiment qu'on avance
si je pouvais d'ailleurs formuler un
souhait et je sais que le Sénat c'est
régulièrement intéressé à l'union des
marchés de capitaux c'est d'y revenir je
ne vois pas de blocage politique en la
matière je vois peut-être un manque
d'intérêt de la part de certains
dirigeants européens mais je crois que
c'est une des solutions à la question de
Monsieur salvaudelli alors sur un
nouveau livret vert LDS
là je vais peut-être envoyer à Bercy
parce que j'avoue que c'est plutôt une
réflexion de leur côté
[Musique]
il le faut peut-être
je suis très sensible à la fin de votre
question c'est à dire que
j'ai une petite prudence sur l'idée
qu'on va résoudre tous les problèmes de
l'économie française en multipliant les
livrets en tout cas vous avez dit que ça
serait peut-être avec davantage de
risque et peut-être moins liquide donc
plus à long terme ça je crois que c'est
une vérité très importante
on ne peut pas à la fois garantir la
liquidité des livrets avoir des taux que
soi trop élevés on va revenir sur le
taux de livret A et en même temps dire
que c'est ce qui va financer toutes les
transformations à long terme économie
française
sur la question de Monsieur Maurier sur
la façon dont les banques centrales
soutiennent la transition écologique
alors là nous pouvons sûrement faire
plus et nous allons faire plus mais vous
me permettrez d'avoir une petite fierté
française et européenne la Banque
centrale européenne est totalement
pionnière nous y avons œuvré à Christine
Lagarde pour verdir la politique
monétaire et on a annoncé en juillet
dernier un plan très important là-dessus
alors que malheureusement d'autres
banques centrales le président de la
fête c'est encore exprimé hier sont un
peu le pied sur le frein en la matière
et la Banque de France permettez-moi
cette petite fierté dans un classement
des 20 principales banques centrales du
monde qui est fait par des ONG
totalement indépendantes et souvent
assez critiques par rapport aux
institutions publiques que nous sommes
nous arrivons de loin premier des vins
je tiens à votre disposition sur le
classement peut-être qu'avec un peu trop
de modestie nous n'avons pas assez parlé
parce qu'après tout c'est un motif de
fierté collective mais nous allons
continuer à avancer dans la matière par
ne peut équiper et puis aussi par nos
politiques de supervision pour inviter
les banques et les compagnies assurances
à de plus en plus vers dire leur bilan
et par notre politique d'investissement
par le rat de la caisse de retraite
madame tout à l'heure
sur
la question que posait le sénateurs sur
le crédit immobilier alors je m'excuse
si j'ai donné l'impression de vouloir le
brider je crois avoir employé
aucun mot de synonyme et je n'ai pas du
tout cette intention et il y a
effectivement nombre de besoins
je crois simplement qu'il faut que nous
ayons une cohérence en la matière
j'ai signé sur le livret A l'actualité
de la semaine le livret A c'est à la
fois la rémunération des épargnants et
le financement du logement social bon
quand on fixe autour du livreur faut
bien regarder les deux côtés du paysage
je crois la voirie à propos de quelques
ajustements possibles
par ailleurs
dans le développement du crédit
immobilier je crois que c'est très
important de veiller le sénateur joli il
faisait allusion à propos des risques de
défaillance des ménages à ce que les
ménages qui prennent un crédit
immobilier ne se retrouvent pas en
situation de surendettement parce que là
c'est pire que tout on se retrouve avec
des chantiers qui sont arrêtés et des
ménages qui sont plantés je peux
utiliser l'expression en tout cas en
grande difficulté donc ça c'est le sens
des mesures que nous avons pris au titre
du hcsf le Haut Conseil de stabilité
financière
d'essayer sauf exception que la durée
des crédits ne dépasse pas 25 ans que la
mensualité ne dépasse pas 35% de revenus
ce qui est quand même déjà beaucoup bon
et j'ai dit depuis le début quand nous
avons pris ces mesures que l'objectif
n'était pas de rendre le crédit plus
rare et donc pas de brider mais de le
rendre plus sûr et ça je crois que c'est
l'intérêt d'absolument tout le monde
donc nous de crédit atteaux fixe nous
avons des crédits avec heureusement des
normes de durée et de charges de
remboursement mais dès lors que nous
avons un crédit sain je crois qu'il peut
être abondant considère que le réglage
est plutôt bon en France aujourd'hui sur
le
votre film question sur la réforme des
retraites et la situation économique
alors j'étais rassuré monsieur le
Président de n'avoir aucune question sur
la réforme des retraites
et sans grande surprise je m'abstiendrai
de tout commentaire sur sauf sur le cas
du régime de la Banque de France que
vous avez
vous avez soulevé madame la Banque de
France est en charge de beaucoup de
choses mais n'est pas en charge de la
réforme de l'autre
sur
l'endettement alors là je vous rejoins
totalement je crois que il y a une
grande vigilance nécessaire en la
matière
vigilance voire inquiétude pour revenir
sur votre analyse des mots
mais ça ça ne peut pas modifier la
politique monétaire je crois d'ailleurs
que c'était pas du tout le sens de votre
question il faut que nous étions le
problème du volume de la dette publique
je rappelle toujours ces chiffres très
simples quand j'avais 20 ans ce qui
était il y a extrêmement longtemps mais
il y a un peu plus de 40 ans le ratio
d'être publications
ceux qui ont 20 ans aujourd'hui partent
dans la vie avec un sac à dos qui pèse 5
à 6 fois plus lourd c'est à dire les 114
% dont j'ai parlé nous ne pouvons pas
continuer comme ça nous manquons très
gravement la solidarité donc c'est ça
c'est là qui a vigilance à l'alerte vous
posiez la question je regroupe un peu
les réponses de savoir si en la matière
la Banque de France pourrait pas en
faire plus
j'ai l'impression d'en faire beaucoup il
m'arrive d'ailleurs de recevoir des
remarques en sens inverse de la part de
certains qui trouvent que j'en fais trop
je
cible personne mais
je ne dis pas que c'est facile de de
faire des arbitrages et évidemment
le Parlement le c'est mieux que personne
mais nous ne pouvons pas continuer avec
un tel volume de dépenses publiques de
déficit et de dettes
et la banque centrale ne peut pas se
fixer comme objectif de financer la
dette publique sinon ça se termine avec
une inflation beaucoup plus forte encore
qu'aujourd'hui il se trouve que quand il
y avait pas assez d'inflation on n'a pas
exception acheté de la dette publique
c'était le fameux kiwi là où les
programmes d'achat c'était une façon de
faire remonter l'inflation vers le bon
niveau et d'éviter la déflation
alors sur votre question monsieur
sénateur sur les maires et quel conseil
leur donner
je crois que je n'ai jamais donné de
conseils de financement et donc vous ne
serez pas surpris que je que je n'en
donne pas même pas un avis qui serait
d'ailleurs très peu qualifié
et ça dépend beaucoup des projets qui a
financé de la situation budgétaire de la
commune etc la seule chose que je veux
peut-être dire à propos de l'évolution
des taux premièrement c'est que les
prêteurs incorporent les anticipations
futures auxquelles vous avez fait
allusion c'est à dire la future
inflation la future évolution des taux
de la Banque centrale donc à un moment
donné les taux sont censés incorporer
des aimants de prévisions la plus
rationnelle possible
l'autre chose c'est que
là je vais m'avancer un peu plus sur le
terrain de la politique monétaire je
crois qu'il ne faut pas penser que
la banque centrale c'est vrai de la
Fédérale réserve américaine comme de
notre côté de la Banque centrale
européenne va monter très vite très fort
et puis ensuite rebaissez très vite il
faut peut-être monter un peu moins haut
et durer un peu plus longtemps pour le
dire autrement je pense que la course de
vitesse qui a eu lieu à la fin de
l'année dernière va progressivement
devenir une course de fond et que dans
le bon calibrage de la politique
monétaire il y a le niveau mais il y a
aussi la durée il y a peut-être
un arbitrage possible entre les deux
monsieur de sur votre question sur
structure alors pardon si j'ai pas été
clair et je reconnais que c'est un mot
du jargon des banquiers centraux je
faisais allusion ce que j'avais dit dans
la partie précédente de mon propos c'est
à dire la capacité à muscler notre
production notre offre à travers ces
trois grandes transformations dont j'ai
parlé c'est-à-dire la transformation
énergétique la transformation numérique
et la transformation du travail pourquoi
est-ce que ça joue un rôle
dans la durée dans la victoire contre
l'inflation ce qui est effectivement la
phrase que vous avez cité parce que en
très résumé très globalement l'inflation
c'est enfin le bon niveau d'inflation
c'est le bon équilibre entre l'offre et
la demande quand il y a pas assez
d'offres et ben à ce moment on risque
d'avoir trop d'inflation
quand il y a pas assez de demandes on
risque d'avoir la déflation c'est la
situation précédente aujourd'hui nous
sommes plutôt dans une situation où il y
a pas assez d'offres et donc ça c'est
les transformations structurelles et si
j'ose je crois l'avoir déjà dit monsieur
le Président devant cette commission
quand on parle de politique de l'offre
etc ça ne se ramène pas à des baisses
d'impôts
j'ai des transformations de fonds qui
sont beaucoup plus efficaces je pense un
durée surtout l'insuffisance publique où
nous sommes
sur les questions du sénateur capuche
sur la différence avec la Banque
mondiale je l'assume
j'ai même la faiblesse de penser que
notre vision de l'économie française est
encore plus pointue et pertinente que
celle de la Banque mondiale mais voilà
pardon de ce réflexe j'ai noté
qu'effectivement il y avait une certaine
tendance au pessimiste qui peut être
justifié pour certains pays d'ailleurs
je prétends pas du tout que nous ayons
une croissance forte cette année j'ai
été très clair sur le net ralentissement
mais aujourd'hui dire que nous allons
éviter une récession lourde atterrissage
brutal etc je m'y engage devant vous
sauve bien sûr rebondissements extérieur
sur la question de la capacité
d'investissement
par rapport à la productivité des
entreprises il est sûr que la
productivité des entreprises est en
train de ralentir beaucoup et elle le
fait c'est la contrepartie du facteur
positif que nous évoquions tout à
l'heure avec le rapporteur général c'est
à dire que l'emploi lui se porte bien
vous avez ralentissement de la
production et maintient de l'emploi voir
maintient des créations d'emploi ça
c'est pas très bon pour la productivité
bon mais je pense qu'à court terme c'est
quand même un mix qui est assez
favorable qui correspond d'ailleurs à un
sujet dont nous avons peu parlé que sont
des difficultés de recrutement les
entreprises dans l'enquête que nous
avons publié ce matin malgré le
ralentissement j'appelle votre attention
sur ce point
52% des entreprises ont encore des
difficultés de recrutement le paradoxe
français il est là nous avons 7% de
chômage un peu plus des centaines de
milliers de jeunes au chômage et plus de
la moitié des entreprises qui ont des
difficultés donc quand arrive le
ralentissement je pense que les
entreprises ont plus tendance qu'avant
garder leurs salariés y compris par le
mécanisme d'activité partielle et autres
ce qui ne me paraît pas mauvais mais
ça pèse sur la productivité est-ce que
ça pèse sur la capacité d'investissement
là j'en suis moins sûr parce que je
pense que l'investissement et les
entreprises est avant tout déterminé par
leurs anticipations de demande et un peu
moins par leur situation financière
l'investissement des entreprises a été
très très bien résisté en 2020 au moment
du covid a très fort repris ensuite pour
l'instant il résiste pas mal je pense
que ce qui pèse le plus sur la capacité
l'investissement et l'entreprise c'est
l'incertitude pardon de revenir toujours
à ce facteur d'où l'important aussi de
gagner la bataille contre l'inflation
j'avoue que je ne connaissais pas l'idée
donc je repars avec
mais à ce moment là je renverrai vers le
Parlement parce que notre rôle ne
consiste uniquement appliquer d'abord je
fais juste une remarque technique c'est
que je pense beaucoup des travaux de
rénovation auxquels vous pensez relève
du crédit à la consommation
juridiquement et pas du crédit
immobilier et que là-dessus le taux
plafond le taux de l'usure est nettement
plus élevé mais je suis presque nous
creusions l'idée voilà j'insiste
toujours sur le taux de l'usure
[Musique]
c'est pas une baguette magique etc et si
vous l'avez mis dans la loi il y a quand
même une très bonne raison c'est de
protéger de protéger les emprunteurs je
vais relever une phrase que je lis
parfois dans la presse et que aucun
membre de la commission des finances
évidemment l'employé mais je lis
quelques fois dans la presse les
problèmes actuels du crédit immobilier
c'est que les taux sont trop élevés le
taux de l'usure est trop bas regardez
vous vous trouverez assez souvent ça
dans la même phrase je me permets juste
d'appeler respectueusement la tension
sur les professionnels qui disent ça ou
temps en temps les commentateurs
médiatiques ce fait que la phrase
contient une contradiction intrinsèque
relativement difficile à lever moi je ne
sais pas à la fois augmenter le taux de
l'usure et baisser les taux du crédit
immobilier ou garder leur progression
ordonnée voilà
alors madame maillet sur le zéro
artificiel je suis en net là j'avoue que
je ne vais pas me prononcer parce que la
Banque de France n'a pas de vie enfin je
vais regarder s'il y a quelques experts
qui ont regardé mais plutôt que de vous
dire une bêtise je préfère je connais
par contre beaucoup mieux la question du
régime spécial de la Banque de France et
merci de l'avoir évoqué je vais être
bref là dessus mais je voudrais juste
dire deux choses la première avec la
plus grande netteté et c'est essentiel
pour l'information des représentants de
la nation les agents de la Banque de
France dans leur retraite n'ont aucun
avantage particulier aujourd'hui
ils appliquent nous appliquons
exactement les règles de la fonction
publique en termes de cotisation en
termes de d'assiette du niveau de
retraite en termes d'âge légal etc donc
s'il y a un régime entre guillemets
spécial de la Banque de France c'est pas
qui est des règles spéciales ou des
avantages ou des privilèges c'est pour
une raison relativement vertueuse et
vertueuse me semble-t-il c'est qu'il est
provisionné à l'avance à 100%. c'est la
caisse de retraite de la Banque de
France qui au passage a d'ailleurs des
investissements
vers et compatibles avec l'objectif 1 et
demi du climat ça c'est la première
chose que je voulais dire avec beaucoup
de netteté et la seconde c'est que du
coup
j'ai souhaité comme les personnels avant
de France mais j'ai souhaité le maintien
de ce régime spécial dès lors que son
existence correspondait à une raison
vertueuse après l'intention du
gouvernement et puis on verra ce qu'est
le vote du Parlement semble être
différente et pas spécifiquement sur la
Banque de France fait ensemble des
régimes spéciaux nous appliquerons
évidemment la loi de la République en
temps et en heure quand elle sera votée
mais je suis clair sur le souhait qui
était le mien
sur la question de Monsieur Longuet 30
années d'inflation réduite oui vous me
permettrez là aussi un petit plaidoyer
pro de mots c'est lié à la
mondialisation je crois que c'est lié
aussi à une relativement bonne action
des banques centrales mais nous n'avons
pas toujours été parfait qu'est-ce qui
va se passer devant nous ce qui était la
pointe de sa question avec la
décarbonation
il y a c'est un débat aujourd'hui très
difficile de trancher est-ce que la
transition climatique qui est devant
nous va repenter un peu plus d'inflation
peut-être un peu plus mais dans des
proportions de l'ordre de quelques
dixièmes de points maximum par an très
différentes avec le choc énergétique que
nous connaissons l'inflation actuelle
n'a rien à voir avec la transition
climatique je crois que c'est très
important de le dire parce qu'il y a
quelques climatosceptiques qui ont
tendance à le dire c'est évidemment pas
ce que voulait dire monsieur Longuet
et donc nous devrons
trouver moyen de réaliser cette
décarbonation tout en maintenant une
inflation modérée ça peut être une des
raisons d'ailleurs pour lesquelles
l'objectif d'inflation n'est pas zéro il
est de 2% je reviens dessus
monsieur à propos de
l'analyse des mots je vous rejoins je
pense que confiance est vigilance sont
de mots que j'aime bien et qui faut
garder l'horizon j'aime mieux ça
d'ailleurs que optimisme et pessimiste
qui renvoie toujours à des biais
psychologiques et
du côté de la vigilance très clairement
la dette comme je le disais je crois
m'être exprimé assez fortement là-dessus
est-ce que l'augmentation de la quantité
de travail va suffire probablement non
je crois qu'il faut gérer de façon plus
efficace les dépenses courantes si vous
me permettez de donner un tout petit
exemple qui se trouve que je le connais
bien depuis que vous m'avez fait
l'honneur de me faire confiance comme
gouverneur de la Banque de France donc
depuis 2015
nous avons réduit les effectifs de cette
maison de 25% par non remplacement de
départ en retraite et nous avons réduit
les dépenses d'activité le total de
notre budget de fonctionnement ma
salariale et frais généraux de 4% par an
en volume après inflation je pense qu'il
y a pas beaucoup d'institutions
publiques qui ont fait ça nous l'avons
fait tout en continuant non seulement à
sur nos missions mais en un
développement un certain nombre sur le
climat les TPE la médiation du crédit et
donc je crois que c'est possible voilà
mais il faut aussi faire ce travail à
côté de l'augmentation de l'offre et de
la croissance dont on parlait
monsieur Bocquet sur les crypto actifs
je pense que votre réponse était
implicite et je la partage ça n'est pas
un accident de parcours FTX pour le dire
autrement quand il y a une succession
d'accident c'est qu'il y a un problème
bon il n'y a pas eu que FTX il y a eu ce
qu'on a appelé Tera et Luna certains
parlent divers des crypto mais c'est un
très long hiver qui a commencé à l'hiver
début 2022 et qui se contenu dans
l'hiver 2023 bon et donc il y a un
problème et donc il faut réglementer
je suis d'ailleurs frappé quand vous
regardez le débat public qu'il y avait
probablement il y a deux trois ans un
débat est-ce qu'il faut réglementer
réguler ou non aujourd'hui le débat est
devenu un peu différent c'est ce qu'il
faut réglementer ou est-ce qu'il faut
interdire donc les choses se sont
déplacées et me semble-t-il c'est sain
le je crois d'ailleurs
dans le débat sur l'epsan avoir été le
premier la semaine dernière avant la
présidence de MF et je me réjouis
beaucoup qu'elle soit aussi sur cette
position pris
le parti d'une réglementation plus
active alors sur votre autre question
monsieur Bocquet à propos des japonais
de la dette Swan d'abord je vous
confirme le chiffre on doit détenir
de l'ordre de 20 à 25% de la dette
souveraine française
est-ce qu'il y a une alternative sur le
financement de la dette souveraine avec
davantage d'investisseurs résident
[Musique]
on vérifiera les chiffres mais comme
vous le savez pour la dette française
c'est à peu près moitié-moitié moitié
d'investir résident largement à travers
l'assurance vie moitié à travers des
investisseurs non résidents j'ai
d'ailleurs noté votre expression quand
vous avez dit les marchés financiers
finances allègrement notre dette
salut votre goût de la langue je sais
pas ce que couve très bien cette
allègrement
oui voilà oui oui c'est bien comme ça
que je l'avais lu je sais pas s'il y a
les graisses mais
en tout cas le taux le taux a nettement
remonté j'avoue que j'ai regardé
moi-même j'étais assez frappé on oublie
il y a un an monsieur le Président le
taux à 10 ans de français c'était 0,2 %
ce matin j'ai regardé avant de venir
vous voir 2,7%. alors ça se traduit pas
tout de suite sur notre service de la
dette parce que c'est au fur et à mesure
des nouvelles émissions enfin des
renouvellements mais c'est évidemment un
monde différent et entre nous le zéro 2%
était quand même anormalement bas je
crois avoir dit à l'époque ça ne
durerait pas
voilà j'avoue être
prudent sur l'idée que si on basculé sur
un financement purement interne national
les choses iraient beaucoup mieux
on paierait quand même plus cher parce
qu'on se priverait de la capacité
d'épargne mondiale
il me semble que le système japonais
très spécifique avec une population très
vieillissante une croissance beaucoup
plus faible que la nôtre vous vous
souvenez que au moment où il y avait
menaces de déflation en zone euro on
nous dénonçait le risque de
japonification de l'économie européenne
nous ne sommes pas là une influçon plus
forte que une croissance plus forte que
des taux d'intérêt plus élevés que donc
je crois qu'il faut pas basculer
totalement du côté des non-résidents
mais
je
voilà je ne suis pas sûr que ça
changerait grand chose si nous avions
beaucoup plus de financement domestiques
sur la question du sénateur je lis sur
l'endettement privé j'arrive doucement
la fin de mes 30 minutes mais ça sera 35
euh alors vous avez tout à fait raison
de poser cette question sur
les ménages alors là je crois pouvoir
être clairement rassurant je ne vois pas
de risque de défaillance financière de
ménage dès lors que nous prenons les
mesures dont j'ai parlé tout à l'heure
sur la prévention durant des demandes
notamment sur le crédit immobilier ça
c'est fameuses normes HCF je vais aussi
partager avec vous une bonne nouvelle
sur l'efficacité des lois la loi sur le
surendettement et puis c'est changement
successifs donc la loi Neyer ce 89 loi
la garde 2010 loi monte 2013 il y a eu
d'ailleurs une forme d'action
transpartisan dans la matière a été très
efficace
depuis le sommet du nombre de dossiers
de surendettement que nous avions connu
en 2015 à 230 000 je vous donne le
chiffre que nous allons publier sur 2022
nous sommes à 113000 dossiers de
surendettement donc on a baissé de plus
de 50 %. ça je crois que c'est un seuil
historique donc je suis rassurant sur
les difficultés financières de ménage
évidemment nous restons mobilisés pour
les cas qui peuvent être plus sensibles
sur les entreprises ma réponse est plus
nuancée j'ai parlé de leur difficulté de
trésorerie j'ai parlé de la question des
comportements de paiement des grandes
entreprises ça nous allons être
vigilants je dirais que de façon globale
je pense que l'économie française et les
entreprises françaises ne manquent pas
de crédit et d'accès au crédit elle
manque de fonds propres
et là il faut absolument que nous
arrivions à développer pour l'innovation
pour la transition climatique davantage
de fonds propres dans l'économie
européenne on revient sur l'union des
marchés de capitaux danger par des
sur un taux de l'usure différent sur les
pmeuses un boucle c'est un peu comme le
taux de l'usure verge n'avait pas
entendu parler je suis pas sûr que tu as
une demande très forte de leur part
voilà pardon on apparaître comme un
défenseur du taux de l'usure mais c'est
la loi
je trouve toujours un peu paradoxal les
diverses corporations qui nous
expliquent qu'en augmentant les taux
plafonds auxquels on va prêter aux
entreprises aux particuliers on va faire
leur bien dans tous les cas il me semble
quand on prête plus cher aux gens on
fait pas toujours leurs biens
alors monsieur Lurel vous me posez une
colle sur le 70% de soi etc donc
permettrait de vous transmettre une
réponse plus détaillée là-dessus ce que
je peux dire dans le principe c'est qu'à
la différence du livret a commencé le
taux du pèle il est fixé à l'entrée et
donc les taux qui ont été appliqués
avant dominoz reste la formule que nous
appliquons aujourd'hui
vise les nouveaux pelles et donc
effectivement en application de cette
formule j'ai recommandé qu'on passe de
1% à 2% sur les nouveaux pelles les
pelles avant 2011 à ma connaissance
reste à leur taux beaucoup plus élevé de
l'époque mais eux ont été fiscalisés
comme vous le savez parce
qu'effectivement cette date de 2011
marque une frontière
les deux dernières questions de Monsieur
Dominati sur le match Londres Paris
et Paris autre place européenne
peut-être un match qui est un peu plus
amical que l'autre mais
je crois que nous avons plutôt marqué
des points dans le match c'est pas une
victoire par chaos mais d'abord la cité
de Londres a perdu un certain nombre de
choses ça c'est incontestable il y a eu
une évolution qui a beaucoup frappé
c'est quand on regarde la capitalisation
boursière de la place de Paris l'année
dernière elle a dépassé la
capitalisation boursière la place de
Londres ça c'était quand même une étape
symbolique qu'on n'avait jamais vu alors
sur le match plus amical entre place
européenne chacun a tirait un peu son
épingle du jeu c'est vrai qu'il y a pas
une place qui s'est imposée c'est un
espèce de constellation mais la place de
Paris me paraît forte notamment chez les
activités de marché fait grandes banques
internationales elles n'ont pas toujours
leur siège européen à Paris c'est qu'une
fois juridiquement à Francfort mais de
fait elles ont leurs équipes de marché
avec tout ce que ça représente comme
activité comme emploi comme pouvoir
d'achat à Paris et je veux pas citer de
nom propre mais la plupart des grandes
banques américaines par exemple ont créé
des des flores pardon de prendre ce mot
enfin des salles de marché très
importantes à Paris ça je crois que
c'est une bonne chose il reste un sujet
que vous avez évoqué c'est ce qu'on
appelle les CCP j'avoue que je suis
moi-même devenu familier avec ce terme
un peu mystérieux que je connaissais mal
c'est les plateformes ou s'échangent les
fameux produits dérivés les swap les
options etc
ce sont des plateformes tout à fait
essentielles y compris en termes de
surveillance des risques et en termes
d'influence économique ces plateformes
sont très largement à Londres
aujourd'hui et elles y sont restées et
là je vais redire ce qui est le souhait
de la part de la France j'aimerais que
nos partenaires européens soient aussi
allant que nous en la matière mais on
peut imaginer une période de transition
parce qu'il faut monter européenne et en
particulier je souhaiterais qu'elle soit
à Paris mais en tout cas en Europe mais
au-delà de période de transition nous ne
pouvons pas rester indéfiniment avec un
marché financier qui est à 27
sans la Grande-Bretagne et une
infrastructure de marché très importante
qui est à Londres en dehors de la
régulation de Bruxelles et Francfort
sachant qu'il faut qu'on le dise et il
faut aussi que les acteurs privés
préparent ces infrastructures
alternatives à Paris à Francfort et en
Europe
enfin on termine
par la question de Monsieur Ferro qui
était évidemment
n'est pas la plus facile pour moi mais
en fait c'est une bonne question pour
terminer d'abord pourquoi est-ce que nos
prévisions de croissance sont
différentes de celle du gouvernement
il y a des raisons techniques
il a aussi une raison de fond à laquelle
je tiens beaucoup c'est que nous sommes
indépendants et puisque nous commençons
l'année 2023 je vais relever devant vous
le fait que grâce au Parlement l'année
2023 marque le 30e anniversaire de
l'indépendance de la Banque de France la
loi du 4 août 1993 et nous sommes
indépendants dans les taux d'intérêt on
peut trouver que c'est parfois
désagréable mais je crois que c'est
nécessaire pour garder une inflation
basse nous sommes aussi indépendants
dans notre analyses économique et dans
nos prévisions et je pense que ça
contribue à notre crédibilité après sur
aisément objectif
d'une part de voltage il faut être
honnête il y a aussi une part
d'incertitude assez forte prétendons pas
que à la décimale prenne notre prévision
soit la seule possible c'est vrai que
l'écart est un peu plus important que
celui d'une décimale mais je m'arrêterai
là
sur la politique budgétaire et je
termine par là si vous voulez bien vous
avez votre question était essentielle
dans quelle mesure la politique
budgétaire contribue à la lutte contre
contre l'inflation elle y a contribué
temporairement ce que j'ai voulu dire
par ma phrase sur la victoire durable
entre l'inflation qui ne peut pas être
budgétaire c'est que plus on avance dans
la durée moins c'est efficace d'abord
parce que plus ça coûte et on revient
sur le problème de la dette publique et
qu'ensuite si des prix de l'énergie ont
changé il faut qu'on s'y adapte y
compris d'ailleurs pour la réussite de
la transition climatique et de la
sobriété énergétique et donc on peut pas
indéfiniment protéger ou chercher à
protéger les acteurs économiques contre
une nouvelle donne
je vous donne peut-être si le président
me donne encore
30 secondes quelques chiffres sur ce
fameux prélèvement énergétique et je
pense que je ne dépasserai pas il y a eu
diverses estimations faites j'ai eu
l'occasion d'expliquer les diverses
méthodes dans un discours en décembre
mais on peut estimer que en 2022 ça
représenté en gros une taxe extérieure à
payer aux fournisseurs de pétrole et gaz
autour de 60 milliards d'euros ou deux
et demi pour cent du PIB comment se
répartit cette taxe alors excenter c'est
très facile à voir en gros c'est au
prorata de la facture énergétique donc
il y a deux tiers-entreprises un tiers
ménage ensuite intervient le budget et
les mesures budgétaires ont été
extrêmement fortes en 2022 et
on représentait ce sont les estimations
entre un gros tiers et la moitié du choc
la part des ménages a beaucoup reculé à
6% et la part des entreprises a reculé
autour de 50% à peu près
ça je dirais que c'est assez agréable à
court terme c'est peut-être nécessaire
pour amortir le choc mais dans la durée
il faut que cette part budgétaire
revienne je l'ai dit d'ici 2 à 3 ans
vers 0 parce que sinon nous ne ferons
pas
l'adaptation nécessaire là où je vous
rejoins totalement c'est que nous avons
besoin évidemment d'investissement
public mais il vaut mieux faire des
investissements dans la transition
climatique que dans des subventions à la
consommation d'essence peut-être pour un
temps il fallait faire la fameuse
ristourne mais
si nous prolongeons ça nous ne
réussirons pas la transition climatique
et nous dépenserons notre argent pour
des choses qui sont plutôt
contre-productives y compris d'ailleurs
même contre l'inflation parce que si
vous maintenez une consommation
énergétique élevée et que les prix de
l'énergie sont ceux qui augmentent fort
si vous soutenez trop la consommation en
général on n'arrivera pas à régler
l'inflation donc je crois que c'est une
question
réduction progressive et ceci étant dit
je sens président qu'il est temps de
m'arrêter il me semble que j'espère
avoir couvert l'essentiel en vous
remerciant encore
parfaitement dans les temps et merci
d'avoir répondu à l'ensemble des
questions de nos collègues j'ai eu un
moment d'hésitation quand vous m'avez
parlé de du 4 août
et pardon monsieur le Président j'ai
redécouvert cette date ce matin et je me
suis dit mais c'est pas moi qui l'ai
choisi
de l'époque
et je ne prétendrai pas faire
l'unanimité des différents bancs ici en
disant qu'il y a le même consensus sur
l'abolition des privilèges de la
création de l'indépendance de la Banque
de France vous avez essayé de faire un
rapprochement
de l'importance des choses quoi vous les
avez mis sur le même pied d'égalité
écoutez je le salue en tout cas bon
merci Monsieur gouverneur et et bonne
fin de journée à tous